[Music]
uh hello uh good morning good afternoon
good evening i'm very excited to have
you here uh before i start the um you
know the introduction of our speakers
and the topic i would like to read the
disclaimer uh this webinar is intended
as a scientific educational session to
form laboratories and healthcare
professionals of related research and
published data
reviews and uses demonstrated in this
presentation may not always reflect
currently regulatory approved intended
uses or claims of the product or assays
support for this program is provided by
abut
so i would like to welcome you to this
roundtable meeting around the um
about the role of recertification for
cardiovascular disease and disease in
coordinating era i'm totally sure that i
will have a great discussion today and
before i start introducing our speakers
i would like to
give you um
some
learning objectives of this webinar so i
would like to discuss what is the recent
evidence of using
the cardiac bear market like high
sensitivity troponin i and the general
populations
i would like to describe in practical
terms what is the algorithm and how we
can incorporate the troponin eye into
risk addiction and clinical management
practices
like to elaborate more on the health
economic evidence of using troponin eye
for cardiovascular risk assessment
and also like to discuss
what are the implementation learnings
and what are the best practices shared
by metgan
so my name is chris varunis i am a
cardiologist and medical director of
medical affairs at
diagnostics and
i'm very delighted to introduce also our
speakers
let's start with our first speaker uh dr
carlos urbaran
[Music]
is a um as a research
scientist at kaiser permanente also he's
an adjunct assistant professional at the
department of epidemiology his current
research area includes recertification
and private prevention so welcome dr
ribaran
i will move on to our next speaker um dr
paul hulicker
is a senior director in medical affairs
in hrr at albert
dr yulia has been involved in the aryan
fhor
market tax and health policy he
currently works in the field of lab
diagnostics with particular emphasis on
evaluating the impact of diagnosis
strategies on clinical pathways
healthcare processes and also outcomes
welcome dr uh yulice
and at last but not least i would like
to introduce dr peter nord dr norwich is
the chief medical officer at medcan base
in toronto he has accountability for
clinical operations quality and safety
professional practices medical staff
oversight
dr north is also an associate assistant
professor of the university of toronto
he was previously the chief medical
officer of unity health toronto having
spent many years leading hospital
organization in canada and us
so um
so uh so let's start with our uh webinar
um i would like first of all to um ask
dr ibaran so
we know very well that
we have an increase of cardiovascular
disease burden
due to the convie 19.
sometimes it seems that
the reason is that
people are unwilling
to have their health check-ins and also
at the same time it seems that also the
coordinating has a huge
impact on cardiovascular disease burden
and i would like to ask you what is the
current situation
and also my second question is
how we can
utilize the caddy bear markets to
stratify the risk and the giant
population so
the floor is yours thanks for being here
dr bargain
thank you uh thank you thank you so much
uh dr veronica that kind introduction
very excited to be here and it is an
honor to take part in this uh in this
roundtable thanks abbott
for extending this invitation i would
like to launch into my presentation
because in my presentation i'll cover
both
issues the impact of the covet
condemning on cardiovascular disease and
then how we can begin to incorporate
licensed to point into into
re-certification and here here are the
two topics i'm going to be covering over
the next uh 20 minutes so first i'll
talk about cardiovascular risk
certification
and prevention in the covet 19 era and
then i will move on to discuss how we
can begin to incorporate high
sensitivity troponinite
into clinical practice
cardiovascular diseases which comprise
mainly ischemic heart disease and stroke
we know that there are the leading
causes of mortality
and a major contributor to disability
worldwide so we know that covet changed
everything so what happened to
cardiovascular disease during covet and
the pandemic i'm showing you here some
data from a kaiser permanente group in
northern california
the first death due to covet 19 in
northern california was reported
march 4th 2020. and i believe that was
the first death reported in the
indonesian
shortly there thereafter
i'm going to use my pointer here shortly
after there was a steep decline
in hospitalizations for acute mechanical
function
in mid 2020 during the spring search of
the first wave of covet
this phenomenon occurred even though to
a lesser degree in the winter surge
of 2020-2021
and the reasons we believe this happened
where the obviously the stay-at-home
mandate uh in in very strictly uh
observed in california and from the
patient's perspective the fear
really real fear going to the hospital
interestingly enough
we saw the same trends for
hospitalizations for stroke
shown here in this slide
but for stroke what we saw was the
decline in hospitalizations in the
spring search but we not we did not see
that phenomenon reoccurring
in the winter in the winter search
covet 19 is a global pandemic and the
illness
affects of multiple organs
let me now show you some
this is data from a recent paper a
the mortality trends
nationally this is data from the cdc
between 2018 2011 and 2020.
that's to uh current heart disease uh as
shown on the left depth to stroke shown
to the right
this lines represent a year to hear
change and i want you to pay particular
attention to the blue line which is the
age-adjusted line
so it's although there was a little blip
here between 2014 and
the most remarkable finding was this uh
steep
increase in mortality
between 2019 and 2020.
it was between these two years overall
mortality include uh increase i'm sorry
by about 16 percent mostly due to deaths
by copying nineteen but it's very
important to uh to realize that
mortality from scheming heart disease
increased by
four point three percent and for stroke
increased by six point four percent so
here we have evidence that you do club
at nineteen there's an increase in
mortality trends for both uh heart
disease and stroke
so covet is a global dynamic the illness
affects multiple organ systems including
the carvascular system this figure is
from a recent
review of the literature
on long-term and acute complications
related to coffee 19 infection acute
complications uh cardiovascular
complications of covet 19 include
decorah syndrome myocardial injury
myocarditis pericarditis pulmonary
hypertension
arrhythmia heart failure thrombotic
disorders
cerebrovascular disease and also
structural changes in the heart
whereas long-term complications include
heart failure readmissions the onset
diabetes new onset hypertension
mechanofibrosis and risk of studying
cardiac death so there's a profound
effect of covenanting on the
cardiovascular system
let's move on now to uh discuss
the current standard the practice
external practice for uh cbd diversity
certification there are several formulas
that combine traditional risk factors
such as the framingham equation score in
europe or the current one that we use
here in the united states which is the
american heart association american
college of cardiology
cohort equation
lipid profiles and high sensitive
troponin have also been used and
continue to be used although crp has uh
this the interest in crp has really been
diminished because it's a
it's a hepatic marker of systemic
inflammation so these formulas allow us
to classify the population into a low
risk group intermediate risk group and
high-risk group low risk group typically
under 10
i risk in 10 years this is for
framingham 10 to 20 intermediate risk
over 20 risk over the next 20 years is
considered high risk and the
recommendations are as follows if the
patient is at low risk then there's
lifestyle counseling for behaviors are
in microvascular disease smoking diet
exercise and so forth patients with
intermediate risk also advise lifestyle
counseling and and there's also a
recommendation to consider the low
intensity treatment if the risk factors
are not controlled by lifestyle alone
the high risk group on the other hand uh
also
lifestyle counseling but uh in this case
pharmacological treatment should be sort
of more of a high intensity level
approach
so there are problems and limitations
with this primary prevention tools we
know that these tools are suboptimal
each of the scoring systems have
specific limitations that are shown in
the slide but let me just summarize
uh globally what what are the
limitations number one this tools are
not applicable to everyone because
they're usually limited by age
or by geographic location secondly
there's great variability in risk
assessment whether you use one or the
other
third they tend to be outdated and
poorly calibrated to contemporary
populations and last but not least
they tend to lack
cardiac specificity
let me now move on to percent data
pertaining to imaging studies
that
related levels of high sensitivity
with imaging biomarkers and i think this
is important because they speak
to the cardiac
specificity of high sensitivity
so the first study that was a study uh
conducted in denmark uh based on cd
scans without contrast and well over a
thousand patients were 50 to 60 years
old without a prior history of
cardiovascular diseases this is the
primary prevention setting as you can
glean from the histogram to the left the
proportion of patients with presence of
calc for your calcium increase gradually
if astrophony levels increase coronary
calcium which i know is a mark what we
know is a marker of atherosclerosis was
the death detected in 30 of patients
when troponin was it was in the lowest
quartile
and was
detected in 55 percent of patients when
troponin was in the highest quartile
the presence of severe calcium with the
darker lines here also went up as
levels of of sensitive troponin levels
increased
and another important feature of the
study is that the addition of high
sensitivity to polymer i
move the rc curve for the prediction of
coronary calcium
which is clinically significant
the second study i like to present
was carried out by a group in sweden and
in this case they uh looked at uh
unrecognized uh akuma confucian mri
the subjects were 250 volunteers 60
years of age at baseline and then they
came back for a follow-up mri when they
were 75
and the investigators related the
concentration of high-sensitive troponin
i have baseline with the proportion of
patients who develop
silent mi in five years and the results
demonstrated a progressive increase in
the proportion of patients with silent
mi as levels of troponin i increased the
perfect from 12
to 13 to 30 percent
i will now uh summarize uh the
the evidence that exists in primary
prevention that is epidemiological
studies or high sensitivity in the
symptomatic populations
in total there's uh five cohorts
and two clinical trials in a primary
prevention setting
totaling 129 000 subjects
there's great variability in the
outcomes that these studies
focused on and follow-up varied from 5
to 15 years
in the interest of time i will not
present
advanced or eric because basically
replicated
the findings of biomarker which is by
far the largest cohort study published
thus far so this is the biomarker
which was a consortium of 10 european
cohorts totaling almost 70 000 people
with follow-up of 14 years
the mean baseline of the participants
was 52 years
the key messages of the study
can be seen in the figure
are the individuals in the top fifth of
the 29 distributions compared with the
bottom fifth had first a 160 percent
increased
risk of cardiovascular causes
92 percent risk of
death by cardiovascular causes and 62
percent increased risk of all cause
mortality
as shown here on the on the right panel
the second study i'd like to highlight
is
the west of scotland clinical trial
uh where travis statin was investigated
in more than 3 000 men
45 to 64 who had an ldl above 152.
if the investigators in the study
measured high sensitive supplement at
baseline and then again one year into
the trial to measure change in high
sensitivity the
the the financial studies come three
main takeaways first one is compared
with the lowest quartile
participants in the highest quartile
baseline isotropin i were at 2.3 for
higher risk of mercury function or death
from chronic heart disease at both five
and five 15-year follow-up
secondly and more uniquely so
because of the longitudinal design here
there was a um a five-fold the
investigators demonstrated a five-fold
greater reduction in coronary events
when troponin concentrations decreased
more than 25
compared when it increased 25 percent or
more
in both
the
treatment
the placebo and the prostate groups and
third this study demonstrated that that
uh troponin concentration
um that problem stating actually
decreased uh lysosomal levels
and it doubled the number of
men whose opponent levels firm fell more
than 25 percent
this is the data from the hunt study in
norway
where more than 9 000 people
were recruited no cardiovascular disease
at baseline follow-up 14 years
and the final composite event of hunt
was hospitalization for a
myocardvascular attack a unique aspect
of this study was a head-to-head
comparison of isensor 2.9 with high
sensitive crp as you can see here from
these two graphs
uh there was a marked uh difference in
survival curves corresponding to
troponin groups at the top and crp
groups at the bottom
and as you can see the separation of the
groups is much more evident in the case
of troponin that in the case of crp
indicating that high sensor troponin eye
is a more selective and more useful
marker for cardiovascular risk
justification compared with high
point i
the next study i'd like to uh highlight
is the
generation scotland
family heart study but which examine a
very interesting question which is is
the association of high senses 2.99 with
cardiovascular disease different men and
women and the answer is yes
this study recruited more than 9 000
people 58 percent of women the average
age was 48 and 27 is a young corporate
and the endpoints included mi stroke and
carvascular death as can be appreciated
in the figure to the left the
concentration of high sensitive troponin
eye tends to be higher in men
than in women
when they analyze the data the at
endpoint data there was a greater
displacement of the curve in women than
men indicating that uh eisen supreme i
have more predictive utility in in women
than in men and in terms of association
the analysis showed that troponin levels
over 10 compared to levels below 3
conferred a 9.7 volt increases in women
and a 5.6 increased risk in men again
suggesting that high tension 2.9
has a higher predicted value in women
than in men
the jupiter 1 trial
was a multinational trial of superstatin
in more than 12 000 men and women who
were free of cardiovascular disease and
diabetes and with an ldl under 130 and
crp greater or equal to two
the objective of this uh sub study
within jupiter was to determine with the
markers of margaret injury high
sensitive 2.9
or myocardial strain brain injury
peptide were associated with adverse
outcome and whether the effectiveness of
the intervention uh statin therapy in
this case was modified by either license
2.99 or bmp
so the key findings of this analysis in
jupiter were as follows high-sensitive
throughput inadequate concentrations in
the highest quartile were associated
with the first major cardovascular event
with an adjusted hassle ratio of 2.19
secondly and perhaps more importantly
rosuvastatin was equally effective in
preventing a first major cardiovascular
event across categories or high
sensitivity and i am bmp with no
evidence of a statistical significant
interaction
i will show you now data from the gases
timing 54 trial a multinational clinical
trial comparing chicago chicagolore with
placebo in patients with polymer
conformation thus representing a
secondary prevention study
the objective of this substudy among 8
600 participants was to investigate with
the addition of high sensitive troponin
intestine to guideline the right
atherosclerovascular risk can improve
risk classification
and downstream treatment recommendations
there are two key messages
that emerge from this analysis of the
pegasus stimuli really for trial data
first patients with lower risk catholics
cross cardiovascular disease
but with high
levels of high centripeta that is
exceeding six had the same rate of
cardiovascular events patients
classified as having very high risk
the other side of the coin was patients
with very high risk of athletic
cardiovascular disease but with
undetectable levels of high sensors 29
had a bend rate similar to those
patients classified as a low risk
secondly
the investigators concluded uh that
incorporation of high sensitive troponin
into guideline derived athletic vascular
disease risk algorithms uh provided
enhanced risk certification and actually
reclassified effectively 12
of the patients to a category the more
appropriate category to for more risk
appropriate medical therapy could then
be offered
so how do we get to incorporate the use
of licensure one eye
in clinical practice
this slide uh
it said this is the algorithm
uh that was uh proposed by ronnie's uh
chair chairman today
byronis and vishiri in a sponsored
feature article
in nature communications last year
so let me walk you through the algorithm
step one of the algorithm is the
application of a traditional cbd risk
prediction tool for example the
framingham
uh score or p four corporate equations
that will stratify
the population in three groups three of
these groups low
moderate and high and as we discussed
earlier uh in in the talk the
recommendations would be lifestyle
consultation for the lower risk group
more aggressive lifestyle intervention
and low intensity pharmacological
treatment if risk factors are not
controlled by lifestyle changes in the
moderate group
and
then for the high risk group the more
aggressive lifestyle prevention and high
intensity pharmacological treatment
step two then
is the measurement of high sensitivity
in everyone and this will generate three
groups
those with uh on whom cardiac injury is
unlikely that uh hysteropoint is low
that is less than 60 men less than 14
women those with
likely cardiac injury if high sensitive
troponin is between 6 and 12 in men or
between 4 and ten in women and those
with cardiac injury present if cardia if
hyacinth is 2.99 is greater than 12
in men rather than 10 in women
so then if in each of these groups
low
moderate or high
cardiac injury is unlikely
then there's no need to for
further workup
if cardiac injury
is likely
this should prompt additional workup uh
such as a stress test or nuclear
profusion test to a for assessment of
subclinical macular injury
if cardiac injuries present
this should also print additional work
up more urgently so i would say and a
discussion about treatment in in this
application
but uh before incorporating high
sensitivity into the risk discussion
uh i'd like to touch upon the issue
of false positives
in other words secondary causes of
hazard supporting elevation that are not
directly connected to uh to makara
injury
so the clinician really needs to uh pay
attention to to this uh to these causes
the majority uh are acute conditions
such as uh strangers exercise running a
marathon something along those lines uh
trauma surgery sepsis but there are also
chronic conditions where is instrument
and i could be elevated such as chronic
kidney disease or anemia as well as
analytical causes that are ought to be
looked at and
revised and corrected
accordingly
there are no published guidelines
on how to address this issue but as a
general principle
it is avoid it is is advisable to avoid
high sensitivity testing after intense
exercise or uh or an acute illness
episode and and then repeat the
measurement to assess longitudinal
changes
so in conclusion
prevention of cardiovascular diseases
remains a public health priority
worldwide
and the covet 19 pandemic
certainly has added impetus for cbd
prevention and to addressing the issue
of health health disparities
i've shown you that uh current risk
assessment tools are suboptimal
i've shared with you also evidence
indicating that heisen's centrepoint eye
meets the criteria set forth by the
european societal cardiology required
for a cardiovascular risk marker to be
useful
namely
cardiac specificity
predicted value
additive value
response to risk modification
and response to interventions
so i like to end with a take-home
message
my presentation and that is that
i like to bring awareness uh about uh
the paradigm shift of high sensitive
troponin eye
from uh being a diagnostic marker of
micro injury in the acute hospital
setting to a potentially useful cbd risk
enhancer
in the general asymptomatic population
and that concludes my presentation thank
you
uh thank you so much
thank you so much dr barron uh very
interesting data um and thanks for the
great presentation so i think that you
presented the variety of evidence
regarding the hair sensitivity troponin
and how we can
have a better
risk assessment by using this bear
market
i would like to have the the questions
at the end of the presentation so
if i can move on to
our next speaker um
so but dr urger i think that
we need also
not to uh discuss the effectiveness but
also the cost and it's not so frequent
to have the cost effectiveness data in
diagnostics and especially for the bear
market so could you tell us more about
the this kind of data
yeah thank you thank you first of all
for the wonderful presentation and for
inviting me here to this roundtable
discussion
i'm really excited to be here and
you you mentioned a very important
aspect i think whenever we talk about
health services new health services
we need to really ask the question you
know does it help right is this
is this effective and also is this
cost-effective so
it's is this worth the money
um because the resources are limited and
um
i what i would like to present here is
really to
give some kind of early early estimates
of the
so-called cost cost-effectiveness of
screening a general population for
cardiovascular risk with high sensitive
bone and eye
okay my my disclosure statement
okay i'd like to actually start with a
brief reflection on the burden of cbd
and we already heard that cvd is the
leading cause of premature death across
the world and actually a third of all
deaths is attributed cut to
cardiovascular diseases and given the
socio-economic threat
in 2013 already the who member states
agreed on a
global action plan that aims to reduce
the number of premature deaths by 25
percent
by
20 25
so 20 25 25 it's quite a catchy name but
of course it's not just about premature
deaths
so cvds also impose a huge
socio-economic burden on health systems
systems and communities just by
diminishing
the
quality of life and the disability to
live a healthy life
okay so and
this this chart here illustrates um the
global burden in terms of the so-called
disability adjusted life years
or the dailies and the daily is just a
kind of an health economic term that's
that is used as a summary measure um and
it combines the information regarding
years lost to
premature deaths and years lived with a
disease so in other words the lower the
daily the better
and this maps this map here shows in
dark blue the areas with lower burden
and in orange red the areas with the
highest burden of cbd and of course this
is you know long before the pandemic
globally the median is around just to
give you some numbers around 5 000
dailies per 100 000 people so but it's
important to know
sorry it's important to know that
there are really huge regional or as
well as national differences as you can
see in the burden and that both reflect
the differences in the underlying risk
factors but also
differences in the access to health care
so the basically the daily basically
indicates the gap
between the current status and an ideal
health situation and this gap is caused
in this case by cardiovascular diseases
and its segwit
okay so
obviously this this this gap really puts
an enormous economic pressure on society
so globally the costs are estimated
of uh to about
1 000 billion a dollar that are
associated with cbd
and only about 50 percent is really
accounted to for
to a direct medical cost so that is the
the the spending that is um account for
diagnostics treatment and
hospitalization and so forth
and in addition to that there's a huge
loss in productivity so that is caused
by
a premature death the absence from work
reduced work performance reduced
employment and so forth and these
so-called indirect costs account for
more than 25
up to fifty percent depending on the
region
of the total economic burden
so
can i
okay
um
okay and actually in light of this
burden and and and given the the um
importance of modifiable risk factors
and issues and access to healthcare the
primary prevention initiatives
and programs are really key to
successful
reduction of this burden
so the question is you know does this
work right
and we already had
heard about the
um
number of studies that that
go into the details of whether or not
so we can demonstrate clinical effects
but
mostly cvd assessment is really done on
or is done with use of risk scores so
the european um
score or the framingham score and so
forth and what the evidence of primary
prevention programs for cbd really
really
mentioned and that is what we already
heard in the previous talk that
there is
no clear evidence
or let's say there is no
conclusive evidence right so and it is
also not possible to conclude that
primary prevention in general is cost
effective
so why is that
why is that well one reason might be
the intrinsic limitation that we already
learned about in the previous
presentation of population-based risk
scores but another reason for the lack
of evidence is a the difficulty or the
lack of randomized controlled studies
and these are indeed difficult to
conduct so the population of interest is
pretty heterogeneous right the
likelihood of an event is very low
consequences may occur within decades
rather than weeks right so and
very important aspect of course is the
variation in management decisions or
treatment effects that are frequently
observed so the question is in this kind
of situation of uncertainty and
ambiguity how are we filling the gap
what do we do in such kind of situations
well
we built a model
right we if we want to if we want to
look into the future you know so we have
weather forecast models and here we are
really interested in
what is the effect of
um using high sensitive bone and eye for
risk stratification how do we quantify
the effect can we quantify the effect
and actually as i already mentioned you
know is this implementation worth the
investment so and the health economic
modeling study
is the tool of choice to answer these
questions until we have long follow-up
studies
conduct
okay so just to give you a few
information or a recap on what is a
health economic model because most of
you may not may not be that familiar
with these these these
methodologies
in simple words a health economic model
is actually
a simulation of the flow of actions it
is it simulates the the patient flow the
cascade of care over a predefined period
of time and it combines evidences from
um
from
several sources so because there is not
actually the ultimate uh
study that really informs um you know
the entire process here um with data so
we need to pick you know so information
from different sources and a very
important point is the extrapolation
over time so we a model helps us to
extrapolate uh information beyond the
the time horizon of the study and this
is how we connect the testing phase with
troponin for example or other risk
scores with long-term outcomes
so
actually a model is a model because it
follows a very highly
a highly structured approach and all
this information is processed in an
analytical framework let's call it that
way and by using advanced analytical
advanced statistical techniques and
methodologies this approach really can
manage the uncertainty in the data the
lack of insufficient the lack of
sufficient information and minimize the
risk with a decision so this is an it's
a kind of a very established tool really
in an early situation of
also biomarker
so back to cardiovascular diseases and
how we and ideas to solve it we already
had about heard about a couple of
studies that really have shown that
considering high sense troponin eye
helps to better identify
those at risk for cardiovascular
diseases
and as i already alluded to
so
um we are also interested in quantifying
the effect
i can
okay
so we are also interested in quantifying
the effect such as you know how big is
the improvement in in outcome what about
the
the resources required would this add
value and would this good would this be
good value for money so as i said um
this is the concept and idea of a health
economic model
and this was the starting point for a
study that we
recently published
last year or that we published last year
and the following minutes i'd like to
summarize and discuss the design and the
results of the study so the objective
was really to
evaluate the cost effectiveness of
using hysense troponin eye for assessing
cardiovascular disease risk in a general
population at working age and we used
actually a do nothing strategy as
baseline and this is a very important
aspect because so um
you
may argue that you know so we
we should use the
most recommended guideline
most recommended strategy as a
comparator however actually we found in
some literature and also we did a survey
in germany that for example
only 40 to 50 percent of patients who
really hadn't had an event you know were
risk obsessed with uh with
before the event
so we can say half of the patients
actually were never risk assessed before
before the event and in many cases in
almost the majority of cases the gps do
not use any of the recommended tools so
that was the reason why we decided to
use a do nothing strategy as baseline
start from there
okay so then actually we assume that
all subjects were screened with high
sense to bone and i and assigned to
these three risk categories low moderate
and high risks and the subjects in the
high risk story receive preventive
medication and this is what we call the
screen and prevent strategy well a very
key or important aspect of course is the
underlying risk or the hazard functions
right so and these were derived from a
prospective population based cohort
study in norway the hunt study
we already learned about that so and the
risk functions of the han study here
stratified by
troponin risk categories
actually
summarizes and
summarize the the
occurrence and the time of all events
over a period of 10 years and more
so
the context is an important aspect in a
cost effectiveness analysis and we
selected two different settings one was
a high income
country with low risk for cvd and the
other was a middle-income country
but high risk for cbd so and we use
germany and kazakhstan as examples
talking about the endpoints the outcome
so the study reported the
number of cardiovascular disease events
and deaths the healthy life years the
so-called quality adjusted life years
and the direct and the indirect costs so
the productivity losses over a period of
10 years
so one very important aspect of course
in the model is the model validation
because
this really tells us whether the
predictions and results are accurate and
robust
so and that of course is the the the uh
sense of everything in in modeling right
so and without going to details here i'd
like to
just like to highlight the the excellent
concordance of the survival curve
generated by the model here in blue and
the kaplan-meier curve from the hunt
cohort which is
shown in red so let's talk about um
let's talk about the results and let's
look into the clinical results first so
in our in in our study
subjects as i said were stratified by
troponin risk
risk classes and about 4.5 percent
of subjects really fell into the
high-risk troponin category and as
mentioned only these were referred to
preventive medication in the screen and
prevent strategy but let's first check
the number of events in the do nothing
strategy so
let's say about six percent of of
subjects experienced an event
within 10 years of follow-up
and importantly
so and that is what we what what the
hans hunt study shows
that the risk really increases sharply
depending on the troponin risk classes
from
2.8
to 2.
27 almost 10-fold increase
so
um
and a fifth of all events
more than a fifth of all events really
happened to subjects in
a really happened in only 4.5 percent of
subjects so
this really tells us that the risk
stratification with troponin really
works but what if we change management
what if management will change right and
this green and prevent strategy really
gives us
gives us
an answer here again there was no change
in treatment for those
classified as low or median risk
and no change in management really means
no change in outcome of course and on
the other hand a significant reduction
in risk and cvd events could be observed
or was observed for the high risk group
and these reductions actually
correspond to a relative risk reduction
of about nine percent for the total
population
and more than 50 percent for those with
elevated troponin eye
well just to
give you
a complete picture also of the
comparison of these two different
settings germany and kazakhstan well
basically the clinical picture was
relatively the same so less than 200
people would need to be screened in
order to prevent one cvd event and the
cvd risk
was reduced by about nine percent
and this really equates to a gain of
almost 30 healthy life years and 1 000
subjects screens so 30 healthy life
years
were gained with troponin strategy
so cost wise actually um
the screen and prevent strategy um led
to a reduction in total cost in
kazakhstan and the moderate increase in
cost in germany so the increase in cost
per patient and per quali gain so which
is the
the standard expression of cost
effectiveness was proved to be
very moderate and so that's why the
conclusion was made that screen pre-bend
was
proved highly cost-effective
by the definition of international
guidelines in cost in terms of cost
effectiveness and it was actually
cost-saving in in kazakhstan
so the question always and i already
mentioned this no
are these results are these results
robust right are these findings
transferable to other countries well and
that is what we usually test in
so-called
sensitivity analysis or scenario
analysis and i don't want to go too much
into the details here but i just would
like to i want you to draw i would like
to draw your attention to the red lines
here that actually indicates the
threshold of cost effectiveness
so and as long as the figures or bars or
dots really do not cross the red line
the screen and prevent strategy with
troponin provides benefit
and remains cost effective
so here the analysis you know really
corroborates the the preference for
screen and prevent
so we it the analysis
provides
high confidence and in the results
it confirms the robustness of the
analysis and but it also indicates the
boundaries of
of the conclusions for example here in
case of
very very low
[Music]
proportion of high risk subjects
or a lower effect of the treatment for
example
um
why is or why was green and prevent
cost saving in kazakhstan and cost
effective in germany well there are
certainly several reasons but an
important aspect of course is
the socio-economic situation and the
local price level and this is an
interesting slide that provides a closer
look
into
the
economic flow
and impact right so
this actually indus illustrates the
investments and savings in both set
settings and the baseline is the the do
nothing strategy here um the indicated
by the dotted line
so starting from do nothing of course
screening and prevention obviously
required an investment as you can see
and please note the difference in price
level between these two countries
so the nine percent reduction in cbd
in cvd events sorry
really led to a decrease in direct
medical costs
um
better as again the resources required
really to treat the events
but in addition to that
we observed a huge impact on
indirect costs so the productivity
losses here
due to premature death as i said
disease-related absence from work and so
forth and the reduction in indirect
costs really largely compensated
the investments
and this resulted in an overall saving
in kazakhstan and the moderate
but highly cost effective
investment in germany
so
this is a very important slide
and this chart actually shows the
the benefit the the size of the benefit
or the incremental net monetary benefit
so as a function of the underlying risk
and also as a function of the country's
economic situation because we use these
two different settings as a competitor
why is this important
why is this important because
this graph actually helps us to
understand
whether
screen and prevent
could be cost effective in other regions
as well
and this is important because it
indicates the range of conditions
under which troponin would be cost
effective or the troponin risk
assessment
so and the dotted line really refers
refers to the um
to the to the assumption in in our study
and um
in short actually the higher the the
higher the um the risk
the higher the health economic benefit
of troponin
and in summary our our study really
considered different regions
different socioeconomic context and
discuss different baseline risk for cvd
and the conclusion is
in settings that fall within this range
the use of troponin i for risk
assessment would be cost effective
or even cost-saving
and of course
as i mentioned we used a wrist function
that was derived from a cohort in norway
and in order to understand whether this
the study results are transferable to
other regions we also want to know
um and i i showed this on the
introductory map that the risk for cbd
can really
vary between countries and regions so
the question was then whether
the data from norway could be applied to
germany
um or to
to the studies uh selected in our to the
country selected in our study so germany
and and and kazakhstan
and therefore we really compared
the official
incidence rates
of germany and kazakhstan with the
incidents in norway during the follow-up
of the hunts study
and the purpose and the purpose of for
the purpose of today's presentation i
also added a couple of other countries
in canada argentina mexico and and so
forth so and it really turns out that
the hunt study reflects the risk in
germany relatively well
it actually underestimates the risk
slightly it really underestimates the
risk in kazakhstan i dare to say
that it that hunt reasonably reflects
the risk in most other countries so
please keep in mind that this is all
before the pandemic
so and if we recall the um the results
from the previous slide so then we can
actually conclude from the study as a
take-home message
that assessing the cardiovascular
disease risk with a single test and then
referring those at high risk to
preventive means
would be cost-effective
the actual amount of the benefit so size
of the cost effectiveness however really
depends on the current preventive means
so on implementation of prevention
programs and of course on the
socio-economic situation of the country
so i i post here and thank you so much
for for your attention
thank you so much dr julie a very
interesting data it's great to see that
this
health economic state and to see that
how this candidate bear mark is cost
effective
and and the other thing is this this
data are quite valid for uh as we know
for payers for health decision makers
and also for the healthcare uh
professionals because at the end of the
day we need to improve the uh the
outcomes the cardiovascular outcomes so
thank you so much we have the time after
the presentation for
for questions and
i will move to our next speaker um
dr nord
we have on the one hand
uh the the evidence that dr ibarren
presented previously we have the
cost-effectiveness data
from dr julie so what is missing the
practical implementation of the
in the daily clinical practice so
um in med can tell us more about this
practical implementation what are the
benefits that you get as a healthcare
system
what's yours
great well thank you very much dr varun
it's great to be here thrilled to be
part of the symposium and and yes just
as you mentioned i uh building on uh
some of the information that we've just
heard about uh a little bit about uh med
can
uh it is really uh what we're looking at
is the practical application of high
sense troponin eye in a very uh specific
population so uh med can is in located
in uh toronto canada
we will have locations across canada and
we're looking at the us as well
and our focus has been over the last 30
years really about prevention so much of
the health care system is is focused on
the on the crisis intervention the
reactive mode uh as as
as things have happened to people who as
their health and wellness has suffered
either through accident or illness and
we have long believed that there is
value and sort of that ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure and
so we have a fairly large population so
medcan is about 500 employees and staff
members many many of those are
physicians and nurses and other allied
health professionals and a lot of what
we've done is build a relationship with
about 40 or 50 000 individuals that have
demonstrated that they care
about their health and they care about
prevention and so we have built a series
of programs over the last 30 years to
support people initially in a very
focused on prevention and then
subsequently based on what we find in
our preventative screening programs
actually offers solutions that are
innovative and and best practice
and and provide that
those interventions in a very timely way
and then do follow-ups so we do a lot of
measurement of outcomes uh as uh to
ensure that our individuals are are
doing well uh overall
and so that's just a bit about where
we've come from and then over the last
uh 17 months we've been we've had a very
interesting relationship uh with this
high sense troponin i in that we did
this in the middle of a pandemic and
just like everybody else has been
dealing with those particular challenges
we have
had to modify specifically our annual
health assessment which is this
comprehensive screening it's basically a
day-long assessment uh with anywhere
from eight to fourteen different
stations or or or assessments that
happen uh including physician including
imaging including a very robust blood
panel
because of the risk of aerosolization
like many uh healthcare organizations
we had to stop uh exercise stress
testing so a percentage of our
population that fit certain criteria
were offered an exercise stress test is
a way to to start to determine
cardiovascular health in conjunction
with a number of other strategies that
we've brought together
so that made perfect sense uh but at the
same time that that was happening we
started to think is there a better way
is there a better way for us to screen
for cardiovascular disease
and just about that same time uh high
sensitivity troponin i uh with past
health canada approval and we've had a
long and uh
great working relationship with abbott
over the years in terms of our other lab
tests that we offer to our patients and
as a result
we were able to
start to utilize a high sensitivity
component i
with virtually all of our annual health
assessments and to give you a bit of a
sense and this slide starts to look at
relatively some of the numbers that were
what we're seeing and uh
got on a rough roughly we will see this
year 20 000 people will end up going
through these are 20 000 discrete
individuals that will go through our
annual health assessment
and so in our first year uh again we're
at 17 months in but at 12 months we had
20 000 people that had gone through um
about 80 or so of those uh individuals
would have
actually had a high sensitivity troponin
as part of their screening and then what
we discovered uh looking at us
a bit of a segregation the segmentation
between the high risk the moderate risk
and the lower risk
is that we had some very interesting
results and we wanted to start to think
about it very early on in terms not just
of elk interesting uh
we have a certain algorithm uh actually
mirrors exactly what we saw in our first
presentation today
and uh based on that we
and the and the hs troponin i result
that would trigger certain types of
interventions votes for the low risk
moderate risk and ultimately the higher
risk and then we have had situations
where somebody presented with higher
risk
symptomatic or
asymptomatic and those those two
populations were treated slightly
differently in terms of the urgency of
the
immediacy of the the next steps in terms
of their their algorithm
and so it was uh it's been very
interesting for us uh to think about
these this population and so early on we
wanted to think about it in in a number
of terms uh including
overall cost
both to med can cost savings or versus
cost and cost savings to the health
system
that we work within as as well
as well as direct impact on our
physician population and of course our
patients as well
and so what we uh started to do is uh
think about this um in in these in these
different uh
ways these different categories and and
uh thinking initially the height this
hypothesis that um that this would be a
value add essentially and looking at
specifically looking at stress testing
versus hs troponin i
and how did that how did that shake out
over the over this year of the pandemic
and i'll jump ahead to the punch line
here the punch line is uh
it's been so successful that we haven't
actually gone back to exercise trust
testing in any sort of screening
capacity we are offering it as an urgent
for those people that uh we feel have an
urgent need for it but the uh but that
was our initial hypothesis is how does
this how does this new blood sample
compare to
exercise stress testing
so we looked at it
again in a number of domains and one of
those was patient experience
for and we found that almost two-thirds
of patients preferred the highest
sensitivity troponin rather than going
through a stress test
and
there was certain time as well so our
for everybody time is is important and
so we we ended up saving quite a bit of
time 37 minutes uh that it took to do
the exercise trust test and the troponin
was virtually no extra time because it
was just added to our existing uh blood
panel
so
so that was that was good um again from
the patient's perspective
we had at the time of our study which
was actually not even a full year
we had had 50 individuals
at that point who
had fallen into this extremely high
category of not just
higher higher risk
but higher risk that had some
significant pathology associated with
them so these are individuals that we
were
very concerned about based on the the
degree of the the results we were
finding from the hs troponin eye so
these weren't people that were
12 or 13 some of them were 50 or 60
and uh virtually all of these
extraordinarily high numbers
and again this is an asymptomatic
population that we were looking at if
they were symptomatic we would not have
they would have been triaged out of the
prevention stream so these are
asymptomatic individuals that may or may
not have had
some previous cardiovascular risk
but exclusively based on the hs troponin
result they were triaged into the more
urgent arm of our algorithm and for
those individuals uh they
they were all referred to hospital and
almost all of them went through uh some
diagnostics and virtually all of that
group was found to have significant
pathology many of them had stents many
of them uh went on to have other
procedures that were essentially
life-saving and and not life-saving 10
or 15 years away but life-saving in the
moment so
um that's why we sort of think about it
as this pyramid on the previous slide
and those people at the upper end of the
pyramid
are most beneficial benefited by the hs
troponin
and so
that has been interesting and you can
imagine the testimonials that we've been
able to secure both from our physicians
and from these patients that this this
this blood sample part of this blood
panel that we offered what drove them
into a system that was essentially
saving their lives uh they were imminent
at imminent risk of having a
cardiovascular event so you can imagine
how positive they are
these people about hs troponin
i will say as well that even the people
in the bottom of that period even people
that had a
lower risk result
that that has value too that's that's
not a non value that's that is a value
that we've leveraged uh in in together
with other parameters framingham
cholesterol values uh we do hscrp for
sure for these individuals based on that
we can actually have a discussion about
their lower risk for cardiovascular
disease and so that's that's a positive
and it tends to reinforce good behavior
and secondly
those individuals we they about eighty
percent of the individuals come back
year after year and so we'll be trending
this over time and if we see that that a
low risk result
it becomes a higher low risk result or a
moderate risk result uh if that trend is
going the wrong direction that is
interesting as well so some of our are
low risk individuals we consider that a
baseline and if we start to see a trend
in the wrong direction we'll obviously
intervene
from the clinicians
we've had
increased clinical confidence and
experience the the physicians have have
noted a significant
reduction in the amount of time that
they had to
work through an exercise stress test
there's a screening
that the physicians would have to do
prior to the exercise stress test and
obviously counseling
subsequently uh about the results and
and and actually reading the tracings uh
took significant amount of time and so
they were really pleased uh with the
with the results uh that that they had
now a test that was
arguably a better screening tool
and it took less time and less of the
patient's time as well
so over 70 percent of the physicians
were actually quite pleased with the
results that they were seeing and in
terms of minutes saved
and although it doesn't sound like much
with at eight minutes but eight minutes
times the number of patients they're
seeing during the day uh adds up to the
fact that they can actually see probably
another patient in the same amount of
time and so that just
was a great optimizer of the day
and then just in terms of cost too we
wanted to look at uh resource
utilization and uh the switch looking at
uh from
equipment cost
space cost staffing cost we were able to
reduce our overall cost footprint by 284
thousand dollars so
not an insignificant benefit for for our
our organization and then when we look
at the health system around us and one
of the things the way we came up with
the saving was around false positives so
exercise stress testing created a
certain number of false positives and
those ended up going into the health
care system
utilizing costs for further
investigations that turned out to be
normal in the end and so
by
minimizing our reliance on exercise
stress testing and moving more towards
hs troponin eye we were able to
demonstrate savings to our payer system
so our health system was benefited
around us as well
so in terms of criticism critical
success factors uh we we really felt
that the um
engaging our physician staff early was
very very important
because this was a new test they they
didn't really know you know what this
was about and so it was it was important
that we
had an engagement process with our
physicians
and so they understood that that
this was a new test but it was fully
fully documented a lot of the research
that we've seen today we utilized in
terms of providing the confidence for
our physicians to utilize this test
and then
we developed this algorithm in
conjunction with our cardiologists um
and with abbott's cardiology and looking
at other organizations and as a result
they felt quite confident in moving
forward with this new lab study
um the the real benefit for them as a
selling feature was of course time
savings so they that was a positive and
the fact that it was such a sensitive
test uh compared to what we were
utilizing uh at that time uh from the
quality perspective the outcomes were
just
remarkably different
and uh and so as a result uh
we have uh inc included the hs troponin
eye in virtually all of our um adult uh
screenings uh our annual health
assessments and so it's been um it's
been an uh an extraordinary journey for
us we're very excited by what we've seen
and ultimately uh now we are looking at
uh and building on some of the the work
that we've seen in the earlier
presentations we are now looking at and
thinking about this almost like in a
very proactive way we're lucky enough to
have 20 000 individuals
many of whom come back to us year after
year after year
so we are um we're very excited about
uh creating a data
repository
based on the data that we're going to be
have we have with hs troponin and i plus
our other biomarkers plus we have a very
robust genetics program so we're going
to be overlaying some genetics
information as well and then following
along in a very proactive way uh our
individuals and following for uh
outcomes um obviously al all cause
mortality as well as cardiovascular
endpoints
and so we're very interested uh and what
those results could be very excited by
the potential and we have this unique
opportunity with our patient population
to follow them along uh year after year
and of course every year the the data
will just become more and more robust so
so based on this early experience with
hs troponin we are very excited about
building on some of the research that's
already happened and create a
another research uh
possibility based on this data pool i'm
sure we're going to be seeing we can
have lots of research papers uh that
could be uh stem from uh the kind of
research uh
potential that we have with this data
warehouse uh full of this information in
the in this population uh which tends to
be
slightly more male but a
high degree of female obviously we want
to be sensitive to sex and gender in
research studies and we're going to be
lucky enough that our our population
tends to be
very equal in terms of male and female
so with that i will uh i'll close we
have a obviously this was a very
successful project because we had a lot
of people at medcan
supporting this as well as the team at
abbott and uh
specifically i want to call out our our
lead cardiologist for medcan dr beth
abramson who has
been instrumental in in helping us move
this project along
so with that i will uh turn it back to
doctor vroomus
uh thank you so much uh dr noah for the
great presentation i think it's it's
great to see that uh
no you don't
uh improve outcomes but also you have
you have a
better
key performance indication for the
healthcare system as well
but i would like to open the discussion
and to ask you uh because because this
is not only the success because because
i i suppose that you have also some
challenges
and you had some barriers
in this journey so uh
could you tell us more about
how you
you could you overcame overcame this
these barriers
yeah i think our big barrier right off
the bat uh was what i was i hinted at
which was the uh physician adoption and
physician engagement we we knew this was
uh was this was an an unknown test and
so
our physicians are
uh many of them are academic physicians
uh many they're all highly skilled
highly experienced and so a degree of
skepticism uh was what had to be there i
mean it's a new test we had to actually
prove to each physician
at a time and as a group uh that this
was something that would be worth doing
i was convinced uh but that that all
that just doesn't matter if the cmo is
is convinced uh they each have to be uh
offering his test to their patients and
uh from uh the testing they need to be
able to uh convey those uh answers uh
to their particular patients
so that was probably we knew going into
it there would be a change management
challenge and so we uh addressed that by
again engaging very very early
that was that was one thing both
individually and as a group so that was
the second thing that we ended up doing
that was very successful the other thing
we did was we said
this isn't a permanent change we're
going to look at this for three months
just three months and if it's not
working out then fair we'll we will we
won't use this test
and that also i think provided them the
reassurance that we weren't fully
invested right off the bat that if
things weren't working out that we could
always back away and so
that offered them the ability to to sort
of engage in a way that said you know if
you know our backstop on all of this is
that if it's not
working out exactly right we can always
revert back to previous change
so
and and of course with physicians
especially data counts data is very
important so offering them all the data
that we had at our disposal to let them
really
think through it uh as questions came up
uh both dr abramson and myself would
answer those questions the best we could
uh to the point where they were
successfully and and um and and felt
like this was something that we could
move forward with
and like every group of physicians
there's early adopters on one one side
and on the other side there's the
skeptics and we're no different we have
a large group of physicians that uh that
work with us on the screening uh process
and so
that um generally what happened is the
the median between those extremes
gradually moved into the adoption phase
and and even today
even though we still have the odd
skeptical like you know a little bit
tough to convince
um everybody's using it everybody's
happy with it
we're still looking at the
results of the of the testing and uh i
think they're very excited to be
thinking about the proactive uh nature
of of what we're doing that we can be
screening and um
and uh
and and go forward in a way that can
help not just our population but
populations around the world
i i think it's it's very important and
you mentioned before about the evidence
and i think
the uh with the troponin uh the issue is
that uh you know the all the
cardiologist
knows the you know the uh the troponin
the acute setting so the
the challenge here is to
to to have the the right evidence to
have the right early adopters to use the
test and i would like to ask you and uh
will let also dr ribarans to comment as
well in practical terms um
do you do you believe that the current
intelligence that
the cancer troponin eye has
is uh is robust
and the other question is what was the
and what is the patient focus
uh the focus is on patients with
previous cardiovascular risk factors
like patients with dyslipidemia
yeah so for our population it is people
that we may have never seen before
these are people that may or may not
have any cardiovascular risk factors
and
uh but
for sure by the end of their assessment
period again typically that happens
throughout a day
we'll know by the end of the day and
have a conversation with them based on
the findings in days so even though they
might be new to us uh asymptomatic low
risk
we find things all the time and not just
in cardiovascular we pick up oh called
cancers on a daily basis
an occult
disease process specifically within
cardiovascular domain so
so our population is is uh is pretty
broad in terms of the risk
stratification
yeah
and uh
i i think what about you dr do you think
that
from the epidemiologist's perspective
you think that the the evidence is quite
robust and
you can easily
set some practical recommendation based
on that what do you think
the evidence as i shown in my in my talk
is sound and clear the totality of
evidence really points to the clinical
usefulness of essential point i
however as dr nord
said there's always skeptics and we know
how hard it is to get new indications
into the guidelines i think the
europeans are certainly ahead of the of
us
uh there's no mention whatsoever i sense
to point out testing in the in the
current 2019 primary prevention and
cardiovascular guidelines the united
states and they really they the the
issue here is that there's no class two
uh r evidence uh class two randomized
evidence all the evidence that we do
have is class two and r non-randomized
so uh we really need to be thinking
about how we can
do uh in a very cost effective and quick
way randomized studies and the medcar
environment i think will
be a beautiful setting to
talk to you talk a lot about how we can
incorporate a a clinical trial in your
in your organization with a sort of
maybe a crossover design or something
because that's what we need we need
more randomized
evidence to demonstrate the utility in
terms of how this is
who is going to benefit this is
benefiting everybody and the med can
experience it that's really highlighted
that if you are at low risk to begin
with a low level will reassure you if
you are at a moderate risk it will kill
the balance to a more aggressive
approach and dynamics to testing and if
you are if you are high
then you you know this is an urgency you
you better get tested because this could
uncover uh a a a
coronary occlusion saved your life so
this is going to ultimately benefit
everyone but if you ask me who should we
start with
probably the intermediate group i think
those are the people who probably will
benefit the most because that's where
the therapeutic decisions are more clear
yeah
i i think at least from the hr
perspective what dr giulia presented
before is
based on the modeling
assess the risk and treat the high risk
so and the other thing that i would like
to
bring to the table is regarding the
the existing risk prediction tools
and um
what is the what is the hr um
piece about that and um dr julian and
also i will let uh the rest of the
speakers to to uh to respond to that so
um do you need do we need to do uh the
assessment with cad with candidate
troponin together with the risk
prediction tools that we have the esc
score or the
equation
yeah yeah well we of course we are
always always striving for you know
how do we improve health right so and
this is this is a continuum and evidence
generation is a process of course also
and
so in this continuum we always have to
understand what is the baseline the base
iron is set by the current practice of
course right so and i mentioned this in
my presentation what we found is that in
many areas or despite the clinical
recommendations most gps are not using
any scores and there might be several
reasons and we had a discussion also
with some some cardiologists on this
but the point is
we have to understand where we are what
is the current status and then we have
to compare a new idea with the current
practice well what we did in the
previous study that i mentioned so we
set the baseline as do nothing but of
course if if um other practices are used
if other
risk assessment tools are used in in
clinical practice we have to understand
you know
what is the what is the improvement if
we add high sense troponin to this or in
other words is there an improvement or
and if there is an improvement is this
actually relevant enough to justify
potential additional investments so this
is the
the term or the the topic of health
economics and actually what we did is
we're also working on data that are
comparing the esc score with a
combination of the esc score and high
sensor port and i and this this study
has not been published yet but first
results were already published in um
was it the euromatlab meeting in 2019
and that actually indicates that also a
combined assessment of the esc score
with high sense troponin reduced the
risk almost
almost
in almost the same size by about 10
percent or so so the point is and these
are of course early results but
this would actually confirm the
study results that i presented and the
conclusion that troponin support risk
assessments do not only improve the
identification of subjects at risk but
really also leads to to health economic
benefits so
basically due to avoidance of of cvd
events and consequential costs but i
think it's really important to
understand again or to stress the fact
again that
even this study is model based right so
and building a model is a wonderful tool
really in an early situation or where we
are dealing with a lot of uncertainty
but really analyzing observational data
this would be the very next step right
so that's why i'm very much really
thrilled by by the presentation of the
medcam data so this is this is a
wonderful baseline for the next step to
really understand you know so from
actual observational data this is the
benefit of high sense 2.09
i believe i believe that the next step
for
for having real-world evidence data is
to capture um the the heart outcomes
like the vascular mortality or incident
uh coronary heart disease
and
i would like to learn more about that
and what is what is the uh
standard of practice
by using high sensitivity troponin i in
medical
doctor know so
what about the follow-up what about the
if you reassess the troponin
uh
what are your thoughts
yeah well we're
yeah as at this point again we're 17
months in so we're just now starting to
collect second data points on
that roughly eighty percent of our
population that returns year after year
so
it so it's early days still we we don't
uh you know have a good idea at this
point uh we've just started to really
think about how we're going to be able
to collect the data in an appropriate
way but uh but we're already starting to
see
you know two dot points uh
for an individual and you know we hope
over over the years that we've got five
six eight ten
data points that will give us uh some
very interesting information on on
trending as well
so that's uh so that's how we've been
so it's a bit early to be talking about
any kind of trending specifically
but in terms of how we treat people uh
obviously there is a certain amount of
and i've had and this goes back to
working with the physicians
uh it's sort of like saying if you have
a framingham score on somebody
um
is that going to drive a specific uh
next step in terms of the the treatment
of that patient well no it's going to be
in the context of their overall
health status and cardiovascular rib
what's their hemoglobin a1c what's their
hype what's their blood pressure what's
their what's their uh total to hdl right
ratios like what's their lp little a
what's their hscrp so i think that's
uh
fascinating that you know as physicians
we pull all that together around the
patient
and then
come up based on a predictive algorithm
of what we should be doing next for the
most part most of most of these people
some of the next
the next two tests would be a stress
echo or or separating having an
echocardiogram and a stress test
obviously putting those two together
having a stress echo
would be the next most logical in a in a
lower urgency situation again that
moderate
group
for sure the the lower
uh
stratification of the higher risk
as well could do that although we would
typically move to
imaging sort of a cardio light imaging
stress perfusion imaging
or ultimately straight to angiogram and
pci
so
actually getting interventional quite
early which i mentioned in our in these
50 plus individuals uh that we that's
that's the route that they took so
the we have this uh algorithm that is uh
similar to
what we we heard earlier uh again
validated by our cardiologist and in use
with our physicians but it's always
adjusted to the clinical scenario of an
individual patient and their overall
cardiovascular risk so it provides
reassurance and comfort for the
physicians that there is sort of a next
step that we that would be logical and
something they could be very comfortable
going with but at the end of the day
i've always said
as physicians we treat an individual
physician as an individual these are all
n of one trials essentially and so the
algorithm is there to help them in
decision making but at the end of the
day uh it's based on their overall
risk uh per
situation that that individual person
uh would be coming forward with
i i think i think this is very very
important how the
you know if you start something how this
can change the clinical practice in
terms of treatment in terms of and they
at the end of the day
the objective is to reduce the
cardiovascular outcomes
so um before i i close this
wonderful session i would like to um
one
message
from you about the recertification and
cardiovascular disease prevention
so we'll start with the doctor baron
one message from your presentation well
i i let me really take home i i think
i think it behooves us to uh teach our
colleagues
that there is a paradigm shift
as instruments
that is a shift
from the acute setting to the primary
setting in asymptomatic populations that
that will be to me is the biggest
stakeholder message
don't care
yeah
yeah i can hear you um i would actually
like to echo dr naughts
or dr north said data counts and i think
it's really important to keep collecting
data to keep collecting information and
learn right so i think we're on a
journey we're on a journey of evident
generation and
we have a wonderful
wonderful
prospects and and baseline information
so we need to
continue on this journey
by collecting data
thank you so much i think it was a great
discussion
and i would like to thank also the
audience for the attention
and um i hope that we will have
other opportunity to discuss
also this this wonderful job thank you
so much
thank you
thank you
you